so looking back from that moment to
before how much did it cost to develop
the pfizer
biontech vaccine
what was it like making the decision to
make that investment
when the risk is very high and you don't
know if it's going to be successful
you know we do a lot of that anyway this
is what we do in our daily work we are
putting money we are investing in
research which is highly risky the
difference in that case was
that within the risk at all we put it
all in
we put everything
in one go so that we don't lose time
usually we'll spend 50 millions and then
if that goes well then we will spend
another 50 and then if it goes well then
100. here we put all together
a little bit more than two billion
dollars 2.3
billion dollars
and
it was a
significant decision
but it was a very easy decision to make
in the context of what we were living at
that time
it was pandemic people were scared we
were scared we didn't know how tomorrow
looked like
we were living unprecedented situations
and
we knew
that we have capabilities that may help
so there was not a second question or
choice we go all in
when you make decisions like that
you're the ceo of a company
that needs to make money
and that
hopes to do a lot of good in the world
how much of both of those things are
part of the calculation
so when you said it was a obvious choice
um i think you've said a bunch of things
of the kind of saying we need to go all
in
instead of very boldly diving in
how much was that that the world is
uh facing uncertainty and fear and uh
potentially
destructive pandemic in the early days
just when you're seeing the full
uncertainty before us don't know how
it's going to unroll and how much of it
is
this may also be a good financial
decision to take this risk yeah i think
about it all the time and i know very
well
that if you focus too much on making
money you will never make
you should focus in what is the real
value driver and the real value driver
it is to
make breakthroughs that change patients
lives
if you don't do that you will never make
money
if you do that don't worry things will
fall into place and also money will
follow
but the mentality of the company is to
be how to help the pace and that's what
the management was that the shareholders
want because that's the only way that we
can create value in this particular case
we're not thinking at all
about what are we going to
make when we sell it or if we not sell
it
because what we were focusing 100 was
how to bring a solution to the world
that will help all of us
change the way the fear that was bring
hope to the world
and uh as always when you do that you
will have good returns as well
on a philosophical level on a human
level do you ever worry
that the pressure to cover the costs
that were invested
to develop a new drug to develop this
vaccine
harms your ability to conduct unbiased
studies
ah not at all because the studies are
highly regulated
everybody knows what regulators and when
i say regulators fda
european authorities uk authorities
israeli authorities japanese authorities
canadian authorities want to see
how the study needs to be conducted
and what exactly they need to see to
approve it or not
so
clearly everybody takes into
consideration how much money i'm going
to invest and what is the chances that
i'm going to to lose them but what you
can do is to change the rules of the
game so that you won't lose the money
there are very well established
methodologies that would say
with very high precision if your
medicine is effective if your medicine
is safe and those are there for all and
or playing with the same rules
you